je vais rendre hommage à une chanteuse
une comédienne une femme d'affaires et
j'aimais indoor belgique qui est décédé
lire jeu d'origine elle est décédée hier
à l'âge de 92 ans avec ses 22
discothèque celle qu'on surnomme la
reine noire des nuits blanches et est
devenue l'égérie des discothèques et des
nuits parisiennes c'est parce que ça
original aidé énormément de bons il faut
le savoir que des soirées chaudes
originaux ml et toi t'as pas connu trop
jeune on a connu les belles soirées des
années 80 et regardant mon truc dommage
d'ailleurs je vais parler de ces boîtes
des années quatre dont la sienne de ces
boîtes des années 80
bayh avait pas hidalgo si paris était
plus
sec en versant hidalgo on était beaucoup
mieux même
sur scène jeudi que la dernière femme
qui a dirigé la france en reste et anne
d'autriche et on a échappé un d'autruche
on s'en sort bien
d'autres les amap est elle en train de
m'aider sur un truc là
[Rires]
jaguar et ça te sortir de la porte de
champerret
résine et est ceinture noire de judo et
en 2019 aussi rigide était venu nous
voir regardez était avec laurent bastien
lequel des deux a fait du judo ah bah
c'est le cas d' armer ces régimes
j'ai commencé à aimer temps et je suis
ceinture noire
sans que les gens racontent que dans mes
clubs comme je n'étais pas contente je
tenais n'écoute pas j'ai jamais donné
tout point il prend entre est très
facile quand on fait du judo onze de mes
proches ont fait doucement et on dit
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas qu'il a pas
derrière
wayne pense que c'est à coup mais c'est
ça qu'il fallait vue graphique voilà et
puis un truc et je l'avais dit à l'etec
laurent baffie sur le plateau regarder
lequel des deux a clashé laurent baffie
régine aux dates jouent
ces régions rappelle régine ou pas away
in avec laurent avec laurent je rigole
beaucoup alors tu l'avais clasher en
2002 vous êtes une des rares personnes à
avoir comme on dit cloué le bec
depuis on est très amis c'est un amour
de m regardez ce que vous préférez dans
le sexe
après quand on rit on rit après
va si vous riez pas c'est une bd made
vous un ep
tu vois
pas déposé